[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
let's go ahead and open up the doors to
our Zoom room if we could please my
wonderful co-hosts folks if you are
watching us on one of our live streams
and you would like to join us here on
daily with Doc you are more than welcome
to by coming to daily with Doc zoom.com
so that's a daily with Doc zoom.com come
on over and if you have questions folks
and you're here in the zoom with us go
ahead and find that raise hand option go
to the zoom menu look for reactions and
raise hand because I will be calling on
people who have their hands raised if
you can't raise your hand or you're out
on one of the other social media type
platforms you can write questions in the
comments also as my amazing co-hosts are
helping me to monitor those different
platforms and bring those questions to
the table so that we can get answers
from the great doctor that we have with
us today and every Monday through Friday
from 12 to 12 50 P.M Pacific time my
name is Becca dukes and as the hostess
of this program I am honored to be able
to bring to you something that brought
me back my life that allowed me to be
able to go from just barely surviving to
actually thriving so folks listen up you
are in for some information that I had
never heard yes I had heard Just Eat
Right
and that's all you need to do I had
heard about this supplement being
goodness and this supplement being good
for this which I have learned is called
fractionated supplementation well based
on Decades of research
of the doctor that we have with us today
your body needs 90 essential nutrients
all together not one here not one there
you put it all together and the body
gets the raw ingredients that it needs
each and every time so that it can do
what it was designed to do and that is
to thrive and function properly so
if you're not thriving and functioning
properly you're definitely in the right
place if you are and you know people who
aren't you're also in the right place
here with daily with Doc this program is
being sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com where we have the Good
Foods bad foods list that Dr Wallach
will be mentioning many times
so when he goes through all the good
things to stay away from
let me correct that when he goes through
all the bad things to stay away from and
you can't write fast enough fear not we
have them at Daily withdoc.com we also
have replays from our past episodes
including some specials that I've done
with Dr Wallach and also pharmacist Ben
Fuchs using nutrition folks so that the
body can Thrive and we also have a store
there so all the products that you hear
about today you'll be able to find in
our store on dailywitdoc.com now if you
were invited by somebody specific I want
you to make sure that you get back with
them to order I want to also want you to
get back with them please and thank them
for sharing this program with you
because we are a resource for an amazing
community of folks who have found what I
found Maybe
a little bit
maybe a lot maybe more than what I
received as far as gaining my health
back
they're in this Crusade with us so we
want to make sure that if they share
information with somebody that that
person gets back with them so that they
can be the
coach
that that person needs to find what is
going to be the best fit for them
so that they can reach their goals as
well
if you are here live with us please
please go ahead and raise your hand
raise your hand early as we do fill up
with questions and we do stop right at
12 50 so that Dr wallet can get on to
his next program
so
it is my honor and privilege to bring to
the screen with me Dr Joel Wallach who
has a Bachelor of Science in agriculture
studying plants and soils a doctorate of
veterinary medicine going on to you know
working with actual live breathing
beings wait plants breathe too they're
alive so let's just go with mammals and
amphibians and reptiles and all those
things that exotic and domestic
veterinarians take care of and three
post doctorates in pathology and if that
wasn't enough after teaching nutrition
at the college level he became a
naturopathic physician so that he could
actually talk to us and nobody could say
well you're not a doctor why should I
listen to you well folks he is a doctor
he's also one of the founding fathers of
the science of epigenetics so listen up
because doc
epigenetics was the light that gave me
hope of all those things that I was told
were genetic and I'd have to just live
with the rest of my life was alive
so what do you have to share with us
today Dr Wallach
well uh more of the truth the truth is
wonderful thanks for sharing your
personal story okay and so I love the
truth and uh today I want to talk about
skin everybody has skin
and in America alone each year just to
treat symptoms okay of skin issues not
makeup or Cosmetics or anything like
that but but doctor prescribed
treatments we spend 75 billion dollars a
year just to treat skin issues we're
talking about cortisone prednisone
um antibiotics all kinds of stuff that
they put on the skin for skin issues
and they're really not pushing the right
buttons okay you'll get some relief
but you're not getting down to the basic
root cause of the problem
and to you know kind of give you a
perspective Parkinson's disease
okay very very dangerous uh disease in
human beings and we're working on that
one too but we spend 52 billion dollars
a year just to treat the symptoms of
Parkinson's disease
and we spend 75 billion dollars a year
just to treat skin symptoms
okay so what's going on here well
everybody has skin it covers your entire
outside body it helps you control your
body temperature keeping it where it's
an optimal okay you sweat if you need to
get rid of some heat
um
you got to watch it because you do need
to keep taking in fluids they don't get
dehydrated
you're not taking in all 90 essential
nutrients as Rebecca was talking about
you start getting wrinkles uh you start
getting blisters you started getting
ulcers you start getting
bugs that start jumping on the skin
that's not healthy uh you gotta start
getting cracks if you start getting
cracks okay in your skin
and um you look like you're 25 years
older than you really are okay because
you're missing nutrients
and so this is not difficult again a
hair analysis is a good way to find out
where you're at and with the nutritional
minerals also with the toxic minerals
okay and so I like a hair analysis
um as opposed to taking biopsies because
you're going to get a limited amount of
information from a surgical biopsy of
the skin okay
um if they're suspicious of a skin
cancer
uh in a small you know it's like the
diameter of a
um a p or a quarter or something like
that they can actually surgically remove
it
okay you know with a kind of a a safe
place around the lesion so that you get
it all and oh good is it wasn't a cancer
or oh good it was a cancer but we got
the whole thing and so these are the
sort of approaches that we're talking
about here a billion dollars a year for
that okay how many nutrients does your
skin need
s 90 essential nutrients just like your
heart just like your lungs just like
your intestines just like your bones
just like your brain
okay and so
um
people who think well I just eat well
and I you know I'm getting everything I
need my doctor said
I just hate that when people say that my
doctor said
well if we gave your doctor a test he
probably wouldn't pass the test
when it came to nutrition okay and so
this is something that we as individuals
have to participate okay in taking care
of our skin now the skin
can defend against bugs viruses bacteria
fungus and yeast and parasites the skin
again protects you from cold and Heat
okay and of course
um you get Clues uh you start losing
your hair you start
getting cracks and and ulcers and
wrinkles in your skin uh if you're a
person of color you might start getting
a loss of skin color and it might just
like you know look like somebody just
took a a brush full of white paint and
kind of threw it at you so you're
getting these little white dots all over
you because you're not able to produce
the skin color everywhere like you
should okay to maintain your your
skin color
and and this is not difficult to
which I say diagnose so you don't have
to have
three PhD degrees to diagnose it and
that's why we came up with these various
books Dead Doctors Don't Lie we came up
with epigenetics we came up with rare
earth spin cures these are books that
cover a lot of territory including the
skin
and when you have stuff going on with
the skin
uh it's kind of like again the red
warning light on your dashboard of your
car because the nutritional efficiencies
that are causing your problems in your
skin are also causing problems in your
bones oh and your cartilage your
ligaments and tendons in your heart and
your lungs your liver your intestines
your kidneys and
um your brain and your eyes and so on so
the same things are causing skin
problems I remember causing other things
so your skin can be looked at as a red
warning light like we have on the
dashboard of the car okay now
um I want to talk about the 90th Century
between 60 60 minerals 16 vitamins 12
minutes and Three fatty acids our skin
needs all of those every day to maintain
itself because it's busy it's got all
these things it's doing to to maintain
your health an optimal levels okay to
fend off the bad guys okay you need your
skin to be in good shape
and so if you're missing one or two or
three or four or five out of the 60
oh yeah that's it come on only I'm only
missing five I I still have the other 55
no that's not good okay you want to do
that don't don't even think that way
okay and so we have
um again our basic core program so let's
start there very very economical our
basic core program our Healthy Start
pack it has 90 solution okay 60 minerals
16 vitamins 12 Mississippi yes it's the
basic stuff that your skin and all other
tissues and systems require
um Healthy Start pack and then
I like to throw in
the because skin
is um a collagen okay it's it's like
tendons and ligaments it's the same
tissues there's tendons and ligaments
and cartilage and so forth so in
addition to the Healthy Start pack I
like to throw in the MSM
I like to throw in the MSM per 100
pounds of body weight you want to take
one bottle a month of the MSN take three
twice a day and it will help you
um support repair and replacement of
dead connective tissue including your
bone marrow your skin uh that kind of
thing so it's imperative
that you think in those terms then I
also like the collagen peptides
the collagen peptides that has collagen
from fish poultry sheep and beef
uh you know you want to scuba that with
your morning drink and screw their
evening drink comes in powder
and we also want you to think in terms
of
things you put on your skin okay you can
put things on your skin because your
skin will absorb a lot of stuff through
the skin okay
there's another surface area to absorb
things
and so you want to
use our plant derived minerals you can
do that on your skin okay now we have a
wonderful story about how the skin saves
lives I mean the skin literally saves
lives Pastor Mike Freeman
okay from the East Coast
big church there he was in a coma I know
for six weeks in the hospital and the
doctor calls his family and says look
um pastures got minutes maybe hours to
live
he won't be able to understand you he's
unconscious he's been unconscious for
six weeks but if you want to come and
say your goodbye so at least you feel
like you've tried to communicate with
him you better do it now
okay
and so
um on the way to the hospital one of his
church members one of our big Associates
was youngevity okay Linda Tyler she
calls me up and says there anything we
can do for Pastor Mike and she tells me
the situation I said well does he have a
G2 so we give him something some
nutrition that way no does he have an IV
we give him nutrition that way no okay I
just want you to take a cart bottom or
liquid and plant minerals or plant
minerals okay this extracted from plants
75 minerals and I want you to take a
half a cup
I have a tea tea cup
um the three locations three times a day
um
up in the chest okay on the sternum and
the upper belly in the lower belly and
then three times in the back okay
between the shoulder blades and the
upper back and lower back again just
just for these plant minerals
unless you can't get them to absorb them
on two and a half days
he wakes up
and he goes to right away he goes to the
church
to where they have TV and radio Studios
he spent 12 hours telling the world his
story about his health issues and what
happened when we rubbed these plant
minerals God's tools plant minerals on
them okay
and we actually made a tool out of that
so everybody can get the story okay
I got it right here doc oh you got it
yes I do oh well there you go yeah it's
praise the Lord and Pastor 90. praise
the Lord and pass the night it's kind of
like those old military things praise
the Lord and past the ammunition you
want to be able to fight back yourself
but you're also asking the good Lord to
help so praise the Lord
and and pass the 90. okay
um and it's one of those things where
um the the the
minerals were totally absorbed
and within weeks he was
recovering I mean completely in a month
or so you wouldn't even know it was the
same guy okay and of course his story is
in the slip chart that's coming out it's
going to press tomorrow okay and he he
has one of the great stories in there
because just using our liquid plant
minerals on the skin
it's like intravenous he absorbed him by
almost like intravenously
and he had minutes or hours to live
according to the doctors
and now guess who's doing his church
meetings every day
seven days a week well Pastor Mike okay
and his whole team
uh is is working that now and we made
the tool out of it because just thank
goodness he recorded
his report on the TV cameras and the
radio cam
um
recordings interview with him Dr Wallach
yeah and we and we did an interview with
him okay and so all that's on this uh
DVD set DVD and CD set praise the Lord
and Pastor 90. my interview is on there
with him his talking to the general
public in the world uh through all his
equipment at the church and so this is a
great great story and it really tells
you the
the importance of
minerals the importance of the skin just
think about that
the skin absorbed all these nutrients so
he could live
I mean
yeah he's got to be kissing on all his
skin all over his whole body okay
because his skin saved his life and of
course all his church members including
Miss Linda you know
um told his wife and and herself to put
these minerals all over him when he was
unconscious and
um
two and a half days later he wakes up
and you know it took him obviously weeks
to totally recover because I mean he was
near-death took him a couple weeks or
maybe a month to totally recover
but he went into a functional state
in two and a half days
after being in a coma for six weeks and
so you cannot I I just I get all
uh emotional I hear that story and tell
the story over and over and over
it tells you how important minerals are
and the good lord gave us many many ways
to obtain them okay including orally
including through the skin and so on
um now we also have hair skin and nails
hair skin and Nails is a capsule okay
it's a capsular tablet I don't remember
which I just take it it's a capsule yeah
so I thought and
um I'm going to increase because my hair
color is okay but I still have some
white here in my mustache I'm going to
up my hair skin and Nails instead of
um three twice a day I'm going to do
three three times a day the Hair Skin
and nails and see if that doesn't you
know one other thing I use Zara test x e
r a dash test and see raw materials for
my sertoli cells in my
testicles to make testosterone we have
seraphim for girls so if girls have
problems with their skin they can use a
seraphim and guys with skin problems can
use as they're a test okay that produces
the hormones which is good for all your
tissues your body including your skin
so
um with that said I I get extremely
excited about the fact that we have
tools that work
we have the nutrition
to be employed by the tools and they
work
and so with that I'm going to turn it
over to Rebecca and see if you have any
comments or questions
well Dr Wallach doc Pastor Mike Freeman
is just one more story of
of thousands and thousands of stories
where you're going from just barely
surviving
to thriving
and we have so many stories that that
are Untold Dr Wallach
on the benefits of the 90 essential
nutrients and all of the work that you
have put in to Bringing these products
to the
to the world
not just where you were in Oregon with
your clinics or Mexico with your clinics
or California with your clinics but
around the world
and yes folks Dr Wallach he has had
clinics where he was seeing
patients in his office
and that just wasn't enough he wasn't
able to reach them the people and make
the impact in people's Health that he
knew God had called him to do
and that's when he decided to
take on a platform like youngevity
create youngevity with the marketing
that youngevity offers where we talk to
people all the time and saying oh I love
this product or I love this book or have
you gone to this restaurant
and that's basically what we do is we're
recommending products that actually work
and instead of just
you know the the company or the
restaurant
making the dollar we get a little thank
you check
so folks it's a great system and it's
been given a Bad Name by some companies
but Dr Wallach I think you were
brilliant in bringing
youngevity to the world in a direct
sales type situation because a product
just sitting on the shelf can't tell you
the story yeah well I knew I had to
build an army that's and I was getting
interviewed
um people were you know the reporters
were always asking well how do you
expect to get this into the world I said
well I'm gonna I'm gonna build an army
and then I should get this big I said
I'm going to build an army and this Army
is going to take this information to the
world because even God built an army
God didn't do everything by himself God
built an army of angels okay and if God
needed to build an army we need to build
an army okay and so I'm I'm following
the good Lord's example by building an
army and when we have something that
works
we make sure that everybody has access
to it and it's one of those things where
we deal with over 600 different diseases
and we have 3 000 products and some of
them are you know you have the same
product would be a liquid appeal and a
capsule okay just like we have the um
the uh you can see here oh the I-26 it's
in a chewable it's in a capsule and it's
in the powder okay it's in three of arms
there you go and that rebuilds your
brain your spinal cord and the nerve
Coatings okay and so if you have
diseases like
um Alzheimer's disease because a lot of
times when you have a skin issue
that's not the only issue you have you
could have Alzheimer's disease and have
eczema you can have Parkinson's disease
and Have Wrinkles you can have Lou
Gehrig's disease
and have all kinds of stuff going on
with your skin and your hair and so you
need an army of trained
people okay
they're almost like technicians and you
train them and this is why we have 23
best-selling books which we're working
on for the Army and of course
um this this flip chart is essentially
a different form of a book it's it's
like a book but it's in a farm in which
um if you even have a sixth grade
reading level
but you want to use this information to
somebody in your family four or five
people in your family or you want to
give it to your workplace or the
neighborhood or your church
um
you can you can be telling the story
to many many people with this flip chart
and if you just read the story for each
of these diseases in that flip chart
you're you're giving them information at
the PHD in medical doctor level
even if you only have a sixth grade
sixth grade reading level yourself
right and and Dr Wallach a lot of people
don't realize and this is something I
didn't realize
um my hair was limp thin
I mean I was taken every time I took my
shower it was handfuls of hair
um I didn't know my hair could be this
curly I've been sick so long
and this is all natural folks
all natural natural color everything but
one thing that I didn't realize was my
beat my heels cracked so bad
and I always had hang nails on the sides
of my fingers and you know I I'd pick at
them cut them and I'd have bleeding
around my fingernails my heels were
cracking and bleeding and that's all
because of nutritional deficiencies
I have no problems with that anymore I
don't even have to think about it
but until I saw a picture that somebody
had sent in yesterday and I'm like oh I
remember those days and I looked down
I'm like I don't have to even think
about that anymore it's not a concern
it's just you give the body what it
needs folks the body can do some amazing
things without you even thinking about
it but being intentional on making sure
that you have the right things going in
and keeping the bad things out
well said you're going to be promoted to
the next grade yes love promotions Dr
Wallach
folks the content of this program is to
provide educational purp educational
information
on the importance of nutrition it is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician the FDA requires us to
let you know and the products that are
mentioned are not meant to treat
diagnose cure any diseases but
it's it's simple medical community makes
it sound difficult it gives these long
names that you can't even pronounce
thinking that oh goodness I have
something that's going to end the world
Well yeah if you have that mindset it's
going to have a poor outcome but folks
when you give the body what it needs
and you have a positive mindset knowing
that God doesn't create junk
things are going to look brighter and
that's where I found the hope that
I needed to keep going
so Dr Wallach we have lots of hands up I
have lots of questions coming in through
the chats and I want to ask a question
before we get into the specific people
um somebody asked a question yesterday
that we didn't get to and it has to do
with honey what are your thoughts on
honey as a sweetener
okay well honey is a sugar
okay it comes from the flowers and the B
harvested and it's um it's in a syrup
form okay and
um so it's it's kind of preserved for uh
sometime but it's a sweetener okay it
does have calories in it so you can get
some calories out of it it does have a
few vitamins in there it'll vary from
place to place a few minerals from place
to place whereas harvested but um you
got to watch it you can't be using a lot
of honey any more than you can be using
a lot of white sugar okay because it'll
give you the same problems
okay there's nothing wrong with having
maybe like a quarter of a teaspoon
of honey
um
uh on your
little gluten-free pancakes in the
morning they're made out of rice they're
made out of
that's just a teaser
okay well remember if you start taking
tablespoons of it you're getting too
much sugar
yes
you're right it has a high glycemic
index which then
affects blood sugar and you raise the
blood sugar and if the body isn't
functioning right it does damage
no matter what the sweetener is right
that's correct and again
um
you go back
thousands of years ago and the people
who live the longest came from the land
flowing with milk and honey
okay it wasn't cow's milk or goat's milk
or Camel's milk it was glacial milk it
was grounded rock dust in the streams
coming down from the side of the
mountains that look like milk because
white they didn't have the ability three
thousand years ago to analyze it and
realize it was a mineral Source chapter
10 of the book where Earth's been
interis goes into the land flowing with
no pin honey
chapter 10 okay is entitled glacial milk
okay
and so this is where all these minerals
were coming from for these people okay
and the Honey part why was why was Honey
always there with the land flowing with
milk and honey well
when you have all these minerals there
are more flowers and there were more
flowers there were more bees and more
bees more flowers more honey okay and so
um this was the good Lord set up the
system so people would take care of the
flowers
I think of Salem uh they had the honey
which they could store
over the winter time and and have it
little bits at a time there was
something you could store without
Refrigeration because it was so
concentrated it didn't get moldy or
anything like that
but the landform of milk and honey
is biblical okay it goes back
um
over 3000 years ago three thousand five
thousand years ago
and
the
um it's imperative that people know
that the the milk in the landfilling
milk and honey is not the same from
place to place to place because it's
based on the number of minerals that are
in those mountains or being ground up by
the glaciers okay and so in that chapter
10 of the book rare has been cures
the chat you know glacial milk we have
analyzes I don't know maybe a half a
dozen different glacial milks and some
of them have three minerals some have a
15 some have 25 some have 40 some have
50 some have 75 they're not all exactly
the same
okay and so
some landslowing with milk and honey
were kind of ho-hum for longevity but
the ones that had 50 Metals 75 metal so
those are the ones that had the long
life
so we've got a question out on YouTube
and KK wants to know what what do you
recommend to eat when they crave sweet
stuff or something sweet
so let's talk real quick about Cravings
Dr Wallach okay well cravings
is called Pika pic look up the word pica
Pica is when you're craving it's also it
can be called cribbing okay we're
chewing on the fence this is why people
get obese they're trying to eat
something they're trying to find
something that's going to satisfy these
Cravings okay and so when you have these
Cravings that means you are mentally
deficient
it's like the red warning light in the
dashboard of your car when you have
these cravings
okay Pika cribbing
okay so you you've got cravings and it
doesn't matter does it matter Dr Wallach
if it's a Sweet Craving or a salty
craving no it doesn't matter greasy food
craving it doesn't matter
all right because I know I know it's
possible because you know I had those
things and you're absolutely right Dr
Wallach when I started putting the
minerals into my body those cravings
went away so I could make wiser choices
and and the way it fell off so I'm down
100 pounds as of right now and I'm very
thankful for that and it's the nutrition
Dr Wallach and the food choices not a
whole lot of extraneous exercise that
got me to where I'm at so
I I am happy about that so thank you doc
well going back to the Bible days you
know three thousand years ago
um in the Old Testament there's 21
stories about the land flowing of milk
and honey there's 21 stories they range
from two paragraphs to two pages in
length and then there's a hundred
mentions in the Old Testament where
they're talking about a person for a
reason they say oh they came from the
landform milk and honey there's a
hundred mentions like that
okay so it was well known that there was
some relationship between the landform
of milk and honey and long Health lives
so there's significance to that land
flowing with milk and honey folks oh yes
I mentioned that many times there is
significance
well Dr Wallach let's go to some
questions and the first question that I
want to ask is coming in
um from coach Rod he has a 51 year old
female five foot five
185 pounds with lupus and scarcidosis no
blood pressure issues no blood sugar
issues Dr Wallach let's talk about lupus
and scarcidosis is it sarcoidosis
exactly what you said isn't that what I
said
okay
all right
well both of those are nutritional
deficiencies doctors will call them
autoimmune your body's attacking itself
okay
and lupus uh you get skin problems you
get digestive problems get respiratory
problems
and doctor says see your body's
attacking itself no
you're missing nutrients and so here's a
case where you want to get a hair
analysis and find out exactly what
you're missing get that book again rare
has been cures chapter 10 glacial milk
it tells you how to collect the hair I
think it starts at page 272 okay
there you go and use it swapped in Dr
well like I just have it bookmarked
and you're absolutely
272. well there you go and so I've
looked at it a few times
and and so once you start taking these
nutrients and stay away from the bad
stuff lupus can go away I don't care if
you've had it for
5-10 years and doctors are kind of
dampening down the symptoms with
Cortisone and prednisone that kind of
stuff but they're not getting ready to
the basic root cause
and Sarcoidosis
is scar tissue sarcoides is scarred
tissue okay and it can be from many
deficiencies including the same ones
that are involved with lupus and it
depends on what you're eating
which you get you get lupus or do you
get sarcoidosis you can have both the
same time
sarcoidosis is particularly
um
normal tissue being replaced with scar
tissue
okay and lupus your bone marrow is all
messed up okay
because it's not getting the nutrients
it needs uh skin problems uh also bowel
problems
and in both cases sarcoidosis and and
lupus you could have both of them at the
same time but doctors want to throw them
into autoimmune diseases where the
body's attacking itself are are genetic
or both okay it's not just simple
nutritional efficiencies
so it's throwing a steroid at it to
suppress the immune system's natural
response is that the right thing to do
no because that's what the doctors do
because in three days all the itching
and pain and stuff like that will be
subdued and maybe even gone oh I just
love my doctor I mean I had this for
years and nobody got a diagnose my
doctor diagnosed it as an autoimmune
disease he gave me this cortisone
prednisone and in three days time all my
symptoms are gone
and then three months later they'll die
because they didn't get the nutrition it
was necessary to make everything work
properly
so what do you recommend Dr Wally for
somebody that is dealing with lupus and
scarcidosis sarcoid sarcoidosis
coidosis sarcoidosis yeah
well they need to get rid of all the bad
foods no fried foods no processed Meats
no oils no glutens no wheat no Brown oh
so buckwheat no sugar no carbonate or
drink some of the diet drinks and
permanent water need to go then per 100
pounds of body weight and in this
Galloway what a hundred and what 160
pounds 160 pounds uh she needs two how
the brain and heart pasture months
photos saying twice a day since two
bottles a month the MSM so you take
three breakfast sweet lunch at dinner
time and they're going to support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disc
between invertebrate bone rakes bone
himself
um as you see here bone marrow so you
make wipeless cells and antibodies and
also
um to
um
help you
make red blood cells for carrying oxygen
around and platelets they don't bleed to
death okay
and how long do you have to stay in the
90th Century as well as long as you want
to live okay uh this is not something
you take while you have a problem and
then when the problem subsides or goes
away okay I can stop taking all this
stuff now
I'm just go back to you know my doctor
says just eat right I'll get everything
I need no that's not true any Doctor Who
says that should have their license
suspended for at least a year and they
should be put into a training course
kind of a jail was a training course so
you can't see patients anymore per year
because
um these things are reversible they're
preventable they're not genetic
um we have three people in our family
with it
well do they all live in the same county
well they all live in the same house
well they're all eating grandma's
recipes and she didn't have the problem
okay well
there you go
there you go so
healthy brain and heart pack
MSM Ultra
collagen
ultimate daily classic
Pro and take the nutrition throughout
the body and it wouldn't hurt to throw
in the um rebound or Sports rank instead
of you know soft drinks that kind of
stuff
well and the I-26 I-26 absolutely
it makes the collagen it makes the
um
the white matter in the brain and the
spinal cord and all the coverings of the
nerves
yeah absolutely plus it takes care of
all those bad pathogens folks that can
be hiding within the digestive system
keeping the food from breaking down and
keeping the body from being able to
um Thrive also so I absolutely love the
functions of the I-26
well Dr Wallach um we're gonna go to the
first the hands that are up right now
and folks if you are on the phone there
is an option where you can raise your
hand also so if you do star six that
mutes and unmute you
but if you do star nine that raises your
hand and do start an iron again to lower
your hand so first we're gonna go all
the way to South Africa and
Albert go ahead and unmute yourself you
have a question for Dr Wallach
good evening Dr Wallach I hope you're
doing well oh yes sir thank you
oh that's funny
doctor my question is that when somebody
has been on uh gluten their whole life
and they decide to
um get off gluten What Happens within
the intestine that starts removing the
uh the gluten from the intestine so the
Villa can grow back
okay well the gluten in the intestines
um is something that kind of moves
through the intestines probably a
certain amount of stored there but
there's a turnover your intestinal villi
are constantly trying to
um have babies you know have baby Villi
to replace the ones who've been killed
by the gluten and so as soon as you get
off all the bad stuff and start taking
the 90 cents nutrients
um that kicks in and suddenly now all
those Villas are growing again
and you know you can see results within
Maybe
a week or two weeks
um and then within months it's a like
you're home free
you know that's wonderful thanks doctor
all right
thank you
all right thank you gentlemen for that
little bit of conversation there too now
we have to go look it up and figure out
what exactly did they say she was in
Africans have a great day
um
and stuff like that so Marilyn
go ahead and unmute yourself you have a
question for Dr Wallach today
unmute yourself Maryland I'm sorry sorry
I was clicking on the road
okay hi everybody say you were talking
about you and said something about
biopsies a little bit can you go in a
little bit more detail the difference
between the biopsy results versus a hair
analysis because you said the biopsy why
is it not
um significant results as opposed to the
hair analysis okay well a biopsy of the
skin
um doesn't give you
um an analysis of the middle content of
the skin
it'll tell if you have cancer it'll tell
you you have scar tissue and that kind
of stuff
whereas the hair analysis
gives you all the nutritional minerals
are in your hair all the toxic minerals
are in your hair
you can't get from a blood test
okay or biopsy
that's why we came up with a hair
analysis
fantastic thank you all right thank you
Marilyn and next let's move right over
to Malcolm Malcolm go ahead and
unmute yourself
can you hear me yes sir
all right yeah I'm 71 years old uh about
five nine 155 pounds
then
pretty healthy all my life because I've
been taking vitamins and minerals for a
long time
um
I've got what's called Fuchs dystrophy
my ophthalmologist says I need a cornea
transplant just wondering what could
help with that I'm sorry blood pressure
what dystrophy yeah
Fuchs
f-u-c-h-s Infuse dystrophy okay and how
does that manifest itself
uh he says the cells in my cornea are
dying they're supposed to pump liquid
out of the cornea they're not so
it's an idea
okay right do you have any ringing in
your ears
no tonight is okay do you have any
balance problems
occasionally yes okay of course 71 years
old let me guess that just comes with it
but anyway yeah no it doesn't come with
age okay what um how many times you wake
up at night to urinate once three times
five times
uh two to three I guess depending on how
much I drink
okay
do you have any Halo pressure diabetes
blood pressure is running around uh 140
or 75 150 over 75 somewhere around there
no diabetes
okay all right uh yeah you might want to
get an MRI of your skull and see if you
have osteoporosis of the skull
um because when you get you know little
balance problems you get maybe some ring
in the ears you have stuff going on your
eyes the skull when you have
osteoporosis of the skull if you can
show that Becca the the skull gets
sicker and it squeezes those nerves
including the optic nerve
and so they look at the eye and they
can't see anything really wrong with the
eye but the skull is squeezing an optic
nerve the optic artery in the optic vein
causing those problems that's a normal
skull quadrant stick looking down on the
brain and autopsy okay up you have to
raise it now a little bit raise it more
more raise it more there you go that one
also it autopsy the top of the skulls
mirror you're looking down in the brain
but you see it's about six and a half
thick
okay squeezing those 12 cranial nerves
now that is not bone that is scar tissue
because the bone is gone
okay this is osteoporosis of the skull
and you need to get a hold of this book
it's on your head it's a book in the CD
set okay which these pictures are in
and there's a chapter for each of the
cranial nerves and then the CD is for
the spinal cord
and there's about a hundred and
um 30 diseases you can get when you have
osteoporosis of the skull okay
and so you've got several of them and so
I would be looking at that
so your body weight is
155 pounds yeah 155 pounds
need to take the collagen peptides take
a scuba that with your morning drink
scoop the evening drink I would also
throw in the uh let's see here
I would go
with the
let's see here the brain we need brain
stuff what what brain stuff would you
give somebody here Becca
well Dr Wallach I think you mentioned
the synaptive if not synaptive and then
we also have renew IQ which is an
amazing brain product it's a yummy
tasting drink mix okay bring a new IQ
okay
and um there you go
and so I you do all those things
um the I-26
um it helps rebuild the brain okay and
the myelin the white matter of the brain
and the spinal cord
and you're going to see benefit okay
but you're gonna have to do these things
you just can't you just can't say well
you know I've got some stuff going on uh
here and I'll just go to the doctor and
get a cortisone shot that's not going to
work
no
um also my skin tears easily and I
bruise easily okay well that's where
again I'm gonna be sure you're getting
the um
you want to get the collagen peptides
you want to get a hold of the glucogel
okay and rebuild the skin don't forget
the eye don't forget the I-26 don't
don't forget the Hair Skin and nails
hair skin and nails
got stuff like that going on you want to
take at least three of those twice a day
might want to take three three times a
day until things get better then you can
take three twice a day for maintenance
but I'd go with three three times a day
and um
kind of going that direction you want to
give your body a source what it needs
because it's not true you can get
everything you need just by heating well
that's not true plants right they cannot
make minerals plants do make vitamins
amino acids fatty acids okay but plants
do not make minerals minerals make up
two-thirds of the 90th Century nutrients
okay
when I can uh
if I exercise vigorously real quick like
when I play with the dog for 10 minutes
I get out 10 minutes 15 seconds I get
out of breath but yet I can go on a two
mile walk or a five mile bike ride with
no problems
yeah well it's a type of exercise you're
doing okay but we do have oxy body okay
we have rebounders for shrink I I would
throw the rebound in there okay we have
the sticks we have the canister we do
have the cans if you're going to use the
cans you got to pop the tops on them the
night before putting the refrigerator so
all the carbonation has gone by morning
if you need something quick the
um rebound and the sticks okay there's
36 in the box we have the canister
there's 36 servings uh in in the
canister but there's no uh there's no um
um carbonation in there so that's good
that'll help you okay
well if you find the interrupt real
quick so when he's doing a walk he's
upright and straight when he's bending
down playing with the dog
he's causing
pressure on some nerves that could be
going on which would just be kind of
more of a effect of osteoporosis of the
skull and I know from listening the
nerves go to the heart they go to the
lungs which could both either one of
them could cause some shortness of
breath and lack of energy
is that
is that a good assessment yeah and
that's why I recommend the rebound
all right
since you bring that up it is
interesting sometimes if I just you know
just look up with my head I get dizzy
yeah I I'd get that an MRI
okay of your skull because the odds are
you have obviously approaches the skull
do you have anything going on with your
heart rate do you have an irregular
heart rate or fast heart rate
no okay good okay I apologize
yep you've got to go Dr Wallach thank
you so much Malcolm for your question
great question Dr Wallach we will see
you tomorrow on daily with Doc
um folks you are watching daily
withdoc.com thank you so much for
joining us here if I could get my
co-hosts up that would be fantastic as I
am
getting Dr Wallach out of the room so he
can move on to his next program because
folks he's a busy messy man and we don't
want to keep somebody else waiting for
him so my co-hosts I could not do this
without them got Sherry Browning who is
helping let people in she's helping put
information and watching the the chat
and also on different platforms watching
questions that are coming in from there
as well and we had questions that we did
not get to I apologize we're limited on
time so please go to our website daily
with doc.com use that contact option and
we will get some answers to you using Dr
wallach's recommendations and we have
the ability to do like direct talk with
Dr Wallach each and every day so we'll
get his recommendations for you and
folks there's a lot of times where the
doc the protocol that Dr Wallach
recommends just doesn't fit somebody's
budget we have been trained to be able
to use what you're what's going on what
your goals are and Taylor makes
something specifically for you that's
going to help you reach your goals maybe
not as fast as what Dr Wallach is
recommending with the optimal
recommendations but folks
the body can do some amazing things so
Sherry thank you so much for doing that
sorry I took that bunny trail
um Marilyn who is putting in the chat
just dictation of what Dr Wallach
recommends plus other information that
is helpful and beneficial that gives you
Tools in your toolbox to be able to make
better choices help yourself and
share with others to help them
so thank you so much Marilyn for doing
that we have Albert way down in South
Africa bringing in questions like he did
today some great questions that
a lot of people are thinking about and
just aren't here to ask so we'll be able
to use these questions as well and
answer questions that people have
all right Albert thank you so much for
just having a heart for people and bring
here with us
um even when it's not convenient hours
so thank you Albert and we have the
assistant executive production manager
AJ who is here making sure that
everything is going in the right
direction bringing in questions as he's
watching the different platforms as well
and
just really helping us make this the
best program we possibly can and getting
it out to as many people as we can and
folks that's where you can come into
play also you're not hearing this
program just by chance there is a
purpose and I truly believe that you
know somebody that this
information can benefit so share this
information with those around you you're
on social media we have a giveaway that
will give you points that will then
could possibly
end you up with some free products as
I'm doing this giveaway those who share
the program
and then first you have to go to
dwdgiveaway.com that's
DWD giveaway.com sign up for the
giveaway and click the different
platforms that you are on but make sure
that you go to that platform look us up
and like or subscribe to our channels
and hey leave us a comment let us know
that you are there we love to know where
we are reaching around the world so make
sure you sign up for the giveaway and
folks
again if you were referred to this
program by somebody specific please make
sure that you get back with them if not
then we have an amazing team here at
Daily with Doc and a phone team if you
call
855-949-3377 this is for those in Canada
and United States if you're on Whatsapp
make sure that you go to daily
withdoc.com use that contact option and
let us know that you're on WhatsApp and
submit your questions there and we will
have somebody reach out to you and help
you figure out what is needed and how to
get it to you so until next time thank
you so much my name is Becca dukes and
it is my honor and privilege to bring to
you empowering information
that actually works bye for now
[Music]
foreign